(Casting)
Guys while you were learning AK sprays and Mid smokes. These players studied the blade.
That's right. This week on Best Of: we're talking about the best knife kills in CS:GO.
Now tell me, what's better than making 1500 extra bucks and putting the fear of God in the enemy team
at the same time.
Am I right?
"Detective Jefferson, may I help you?"
"I'll call you back."
And we're not just dealing with the sneaky beaky knife kills either.
Oh no we're gonna show you the best yolo don't give a f*ck knife kills. And the best worst knife kills.
Which I guess you call fails.
(Casting)
So let's start things off with some stealthy knife plays, that'll make you wanna smile.
"Ear to ear."
(Casting)
Guys we've all played pub games where the only logical conclusion comes down to whip out the knife.
I mean run out of bullets? Whip out the knife? Enemy with his back turned? Whip out the knife.
Round gone to sh*t, entire team on tilt? You know what to do.
Whip out the knife.
"I can beat you. I don't need no gun."
"I'm gonna kill you now."
(Casting)
Guys getting a kill with your knife is one of the best feelings you can have in a competitive CS:GO match.
"I gotta tell ya, this is pretty terrific. Yeah!"
I mean, you make extra money. You put the entire enemy team on tilt. And you kinda feel like a bada*s.
But sometimes guys, sometimes pulling out the knife is not the right plan.
"Agh! I did not see that coming."
(Casting)
Well guys that's it for Best Of: this week. I hope you got your fill on butterfly flipping rampant spinning action.
Now go ahead and stab that subscribe button, and I'll see ya next week.
So let's start things off with some stealthy knife plays, that'll make you wanna smile. Ear to ear.
Ehehehehehehe.